I feel very pale I'm wearing a [ __ ] ton
of makeup it looked like I have no
features right can you see them in there
is that just bright I'm Greg
ahh and Ariana has made her introduction
people that was me
I just always look like I'm not wearing
makeup okay
and I'm Ariana boxer well um as little
fun
sting at Ariana on my end cuz Will Smith
and Margot Robbie insult each other and
this segment on BBC radio that I
actually really love
I saw Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg do
it um close to each other yeah they just
go back and front first one to laugh
loses like really just wow that's fun
and Chloe grace Moretz and Seth Rogen
did it what's a funny pairing well they
were neighbors together you know it's
emotional and Margot Robbie I understand
how promotions and Wilson are right but
the movie focused together so the road
again Suicide Squad together ah is Will
Smith not Suicide Squad I think it was
another black actor well don't put that
on me I'm looking at a little bit
Suicide Squad
I don't think they well they're also
InFocus yeah don't worry hi I'm telling
you the truth just like to keep myself
open for that's how you attract those
things because you keep worrying about
ah what one thinking about the negative
doesn't ways let's just think about the
positive things yeah but you think about
the negatives enough it's like zombies
in a movie in like a movie not one
zombie can really hurt you could kill it
but a bunch of zombies like I'm wearing
more makeup now though yeah you look
totally awesome
no look like my faces look fine
yeah but give me a chance yeah I'm
trying to be nice to you uh-huh
okay let's watch this let's react funny
have something else from BBC Radio 1 and
our Chris Rock we're with Will Smith and
Margot Robbie and robots play our game
there's insults they are sitting face to
face both staring each other out please
don't hold that guys we know very
attract what said in this room it's just
a game it's safe though neither of you
should take the insults personally you
work together a few times the insults
will leave the room when you do all you
have to do is try and make the other
laugh so the city are the insult the
better I think today Margot Robbie to
start excited did your ears stick out so
much I could use them as antennas and
connect to the Wi-Fi in my mom South
Australia there any law has to be like
she's gonna watch see this is the
problem you know too much we all waited
or you could use your finding Dory pins
on your sweater to contact your mom
underwater telepathic wait that's how we
do it mister yeah so our thing
very if you like I missed it now as you
were talking Ariane never had a banner
read well it happened I will the rules
they're pretty lenient on but the basic
rule is that ever if I've land an insult
on you and you immediately crack up just
from that insult like not like you wait
a while okay they can't laugh
immediately yeah
well then not like you know whatever
they're leaning on the rules or wind
this back correct writing your purpose
one minute thirty seconds I missed it
won't work funny if it's in the moment
yes so I had to Google the first
principle of didn't know what it was
haven't even heard of it mmm I just
can't do tomatoes
you were the worst looking cast member
in I imagined new zombies and all in a
dog I was she lost yeah not again she
thought your nickname was Big Willie
but haha
so misled by that the drain I almost
like your outfit today as much as I like
your outfit we getting TV with a video
the Egyptian part yes you dress yeah
does a Pharaoh Pharaoh
- no apparent reason she's definitely a
man will snoop a lot of [ __ ] look like a
less hot version of Obama you like Obama
but not as hot Vibha more games on
content roles of a 20 year old but the
hearing of a 90 year old should I say
whoa murder Robbie's awesome you just
got me you know you know they've got me
on my heels
yeah I'm ready for ya I'll get you those
- nice - nice my good my next one for
you - I'm so annoying dick Queens on
your pants this is 0.12
in Europe these are known as Prince
Albert's to be of a total of eight
Prince Albert's is the penguin of your
life is 8th Prince Albert less dogs out
there looking for them they couldn't
even Pierce yours small yeah we got
there or there
ah Chloe your lovely lady supposing the
different dynamics from the curry I've
seen with Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg
they went back and forth a lot and I was
really funny
mm-hmm Seth Rogen he could have like I
saw a whole version he could have easily
gone really crude and mean but he
actually held back a lot because she's
like only 18 or something you know hey
um I don't know if that matters them and
in this one I thought it was great to
see Margot Robbie just deliver like as
I'm as a woman just delivering on the
insults like that and Will Smith just
taking it that was like an old woman
because it's not often that you get to
see an actress really go all out with a
joke like that or a game like that
especially when they're just being
themselves look at Will Smith for
example maybe he's just treating her
like a lady maybe he's just being the
gentleman and not insulting her however
you [ __ ] her mom he's he slept with
her mom but she had a great comeback it
was Big Willy Edition it I just love how
she was on a roll that made her like a
lot hotter Wow the fact that she can
really dish it I'm not gonna go there
with that territory but just it's cool
that you can do that Margot Robbie I'm
in enough sex jokes in my day and it's
not gonna continue now this must be hard
on you
ah I feel like you're like two Brits I
do love them I think they're so cute so
funny but I also think they're not great
at knowing you know the rule I noticed
you were really I carry BBC America we
care about the rules ah there laughing
cut it cut it cut it game over you don't
a four minutes segment or give a penalty
a penalty that's strike three three
laughs you're out yeah the water
balloons this is what yeah now it's just
like insult each other for as long as
you want there's no game at that point
I need points we please I need
structures we rest there the revs oh
nothing
ah so we do it in America
abomination not for my father we're
dealing with a lot of scary stuff over
here yeah never mind we don't have time
to insult each other over here
yeah we have to work together she knew a
lot about Will Smith yeah she was
clearly a huge fan of all she's pretty
young and she's grown up on like all the
same stuff I grew up on Fresh Prince of
bel-air right getting Jim Irwin gettin
jiggy where they came out get jiggy wit
it Nana Nana Nana I don't remember that
Faro part I didn't look that up that was
a great musically I've seen so many
times Fresh Prince of bel-air judwaa
Chester yeah of course that's amazing
about Fresh Prince a lot yeah one thing
for sure is that even though Will Smith
is superstar Will Smith if you watch
Fresh Prince of bel-air you're not aware
of that
he's just who he is on the show you know
yeah and I think that's really cool to
see how much he's grown When Will Smith
got into Fresh Prince he had never had
acting classes he was just a famous
rapper and they gave him the show like
one of those kind of deals yeah he
learned to make it work and he learn to
get better he learned to acne got better
and like that's one of my all-time
favorite shows I love Will Smith he's
great
Scientologist cameras Anika ah why do
you say that why asking thank you yes I
don't think he's a Scientologist I think
he's just you know like good friends
talk
who cares if he's a Scientologist hmm I
say you not care I mean no not really I
love Tom cruising they broke up with
Scientology Ariana 80% of the fan base
or Scientologist on this channel what
most of most of the fans of subscribers
you're Scientologists hey Tommy what mr.
demographic yeah I totally believe you
oh the demographics came in Oh
Scientologists I've heard rumors about
Will Smith Scientology one guy is
actually gay buddy great that'd be great
uh-huh make a lot of men happy that he's
an [ __ ] on set
really yeah and I've heard this from
like six people who just swear by it
six people cuz of a couple of
interactions they had with the guy
there's a lot of people I would say out
of how many people is will so have to
interact with on a daily is about that I
think about oh my god if you become
famous you really do have to just be so
nice all the time I think that's like
sometimes someone who can't give you
their undivided attention or give me
attention you're distracting him from
his job yeah from him delivering what
she loved without him you're distracting
him so for you Will Smith haters [ __ ]
you Margot Robbie love you I want you to
have a child
nom I can't handle the respond her to
have a child just wanted to have a shot
that should be a beautiful mom that's a
compliment Margot
you look great with a pregnant belly are
you do you like fetishize that
alright nuff said subscribe
that's good Ariana's on Instagram and
she's at the ice pick factory oh my god
[ __ ] ice house guys yeah I sabes Jay
Leno used to perform there Oh Jean Leno
I love Leno remember what he did in
Conan okay fine and then Comedy Store on
August 24 it I love the Comedy Store my
favorite stand-up place whatever comedy
club yeah to go to ever I've been to
three two of them were me exactly
I've been to the Congress store without
you there and flappers I usually forget
you're performing and I go to Y go
Wessel